willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns mit max webers begriff der scham
befassen werden dass es ein text gelesen
wir der richter nicht gerecht
vielleicht auch ein bisschen unzeitgemäß
ist in vielen seiner aussagen also das
problematisch das wollen wir heute gar
nicht verschweigen aber der trotz dieser
unzeitgemäß halt und irritation der
zumindest auf mich ausübt hat dennoch
irgendwie interessante einsichten hält
aber es ist ein text der sicherlich
provoziert beim lesen
das möchte ich nicht verschweigen so
alles geht über die scham ist ein thema
über das man sich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen schämt wenn man es liest sogar
eine performative text gewissermaßen
jetzt gehe ich aber noch mal kurz auf
dem seminarplan ein weil ich jetzt noch
übersicht geben möchte für das was uns
noch erwartet die gemeinsam also wir
werden jetzt noch was über die chancen
der heutigen sitzung dann geht es aber
der nächsten sitzung gleich weiter mit
dem ekel und wir werden heute sehen dass
der ekel und die schaden sehr eng
verwandt sind und zum ekel werden wir
text vorlesen aus dem gleichnamigen buch
dann gehts der der aufwand sitzung über
die verzweiflung weil sie die angst die
auch bei chilliger aber meine heiliger
sehr zentral ist dann um die leiter die
eifersucht da habe ich momentan vor auf
platon aristoteles einzugehen als auf
die antiken philosophen vielleicht finde
ich auch noch etwas neueres dann geben
auf dem haus ein
hier habe ich es ja noch keine
philosophen oder keinen philosophen da
können sie gerne vorschläge machen
wir haben auch unten im kommentaren
youtube video dann geht es in den
letzten beiden sitzungen und liebe bei
augustinus und hannah arendt und bei
harry frank für das soll der restliche
seminarplan sein und jetzt zu den
heutigen fragen inwiefern handelt ist
bei der schaffung einer emotion
emotionen wie wir sie kennen
gelernt haben das heißt konkret geben um
ein phänomen was urteils charakter
motivation charakter und gefühls
charakter hat wie stern findet sich in
der scheune urteils motivation zum
gefühlt dimension wie manifestiert sich
schon phänomenal also ich bin der
meinung und das sehen wir jetzt auch
noch in den texten sie gelesen dass sich
charme durchaus zeigt also schaden tritt
nach außen hat eine körperliche seite
andere emotionen nicht so sehr wie zum
beispiel der neid der zeigt sich in
meinen augen nicht hier besteht gerade
darin sich zu verbergen
die schwarm tritt aber doch nach außen
wie lässt sich die schaden von
verwandten emotionen unterschreiben
intext werden wir hier den ekel finden
auch die liebe wie grenzt max er die
scheiben von rein biologischen
auffassungen ab gleich zu beginn unserer
lektüre werden wir hier einen
interessanten text 10
und zum schluss ich habe es aber auch
schon genannt inwiefern ist das
auffassung der schaben problematisch ich
will nicht verschweigen dass dieser text
ja die mehr ganz zeitgemäß sind mann und
seine aussagen aber wir müssen immer das
prinzip der menschenfreundlichkeit
walten lassen das heißt immer so viel
positives aus dem text nehmen auch wenn
eher problematisch stellen enthält so
noch eine person das ich eintreten und
jetzt geht es hier gerade weiter was zur
person von max scheler sage ich also max
scheler war ein deutscher phänomenologie
so könnte man es ganz kurz fassen es
nicht sonderlich alt geworden
manche bezahlten ihn als ein bilderbuch
phänomenologie weil er immer so
treffende bilder oder beispiele hat
manchmal auch nicht zutreffende aber
irgendwie plakativ etwas plakativ ist
was auf den ersten blick einleuchtend
erscheint und auf den zweiten muss man
schon noch so einen dienst dann befasste
sich in seiner vielzahl dieser
philosophischen werke und anthropologie
also der lehre von menschen der
soziologie ethik und religion und eben
immer mit dieser phänomenologischen
methode
ich komme gleich darauf den begriff
genauer zu sprechen schily vertrat unter
anderem die these dass die moralische
werte fühlen können also einen
emotionalen zugang zu werten haben
das ist eine starke these dagegen wird
in die partie oder auch schon immer
bestritten wurde das überhaupt werte
gibt und dass wir werte fühlen können
sie jetzt heraus dass es sie gibt und
das wird zu ihm dem system ist noch
besondere zu gelangen
das macht die sache natürlich noch ein
bisschen schwieriger und jetzt hat er
eben einen kurzen text geschrieben der
aus einem nachlass stand also wohl eher
so früh geschrieben wurde
in diesem werk ausgabe die ich habe
digital ist ein nachlass enthalten von
einer 13
also über 100 jahre alt überschreiben
und schamgefühl
er spricht jetzt von schamgefühl wir
werden aber sehen dass schiller durchaus
auch von der scham als einer emotion
spricht erscheint gefühle und emotionen
nicht ganz schaffen oder zu
unterscheiden
vielleicht hängt es damals sagen dass er
damit verschiedene aspekte die emotion
charme bezeichnen möchte wir haben ja
gesehen emotionen haben wir auch eine
gefühl zeit
das ist der text und jetzt möchte ich
aber ihn noch kurz einem kollegen ein
video auf youtube auf die lowcost
welches genau dem thema für neurologie
gewidmet ist ich mach oben rechts
nachher im video dann den link zu diesem
video hinein und auch und in der
beschreibung von meinem kollegen
christoph ehrhardt der dein und
interviews mit mir ein bisschen weil
diese phänomene logan diese unheilige
gesprochen hat und dieses wiederum hat
schon ziemlich viele aufrufe und sollen
aber weitere aufrufe gekommen
ich glaube da können sie viel davon
profitieren so aber jetzt gehen wir mit
den text hinein also max scheler sagt
wird sie diesen text ähnlich wie die
worte liebe und sinnlichkeit sinne zu
gleicher zeit eine elementare tatsache
unseres geistigen bzw
psychischen lebens bezeichnen für welche
geschlechtsleben geschlechtliche
sinnlichkeit und empfindungen über
spezialfälle darstellen aber in einem
prägnanten gebrauch auch ohne weiteren
zusatz die letztgenannten tatsachen
allein bezeichnen können so hat auch das
opfer diese charakteristische
doppelbedeutung zu wenig diese tat
zufall ist sondern tief in den
phänomenen selbst gegründet so darf sie
doch nicht zu einer annahme zu führen zu
der sie die naturalistische philosophie
häufig verführt hat so der anlage
nämlich dass die uhr phänomene die wir
mit diesen worten bezeichnet selbst
ausschließlich tatsache dass geschichten
erotischen lebens sein und das erst eine
assoziative verknüpfen dieser phänomene
mit hauser geschlechtlichen tatsache
oder eine genetische weiterbildung der
erlebnis tatsachen eine mehrere weniger
bloß analoge übertragung der betrifft
sollte auf hause geschlechtlichen
erlebnisse veranlasst habe oder ist ein
langer zitat gewesen was wir damit sagen
er wendet sich gegen eine
naturalistische auffassung von emotionen
wie zum beispiel der schaden könnte auch
sagen gegen eine reduktionistischen
auffassung die der charme allein eine
biologische ursache sieht eine
körperliche ursache
er bestreitet das nicht das schreiben
eine körperliche seite hat habe er sagt
das ist das wäre zu wenig und die schau
als emotionen philosophisch in ihrer
ganzheitlichen phänomenal i tät zu
verstehen
er spricht auch hier für einen phänomen
sie sehen also hat die phänologischen
tode sich zu eigen gemacht bei der
analyse charme ok er bestreitet diese
ansicht dass charme allein körperlich
ist naturalistisches phänomen zeit und
dass die scham von dem man dann im
abstrakteren oder kulturellen sinne
spricht dass die nur eine ableitung sei
eine bloß einer logischen neutral kommt
also eine ureigene die bedeutung des
wortes also eine scham in
anführungsstriche zu sagen die nur
abgeleitet charme ist sind die
eigentlich ursprünglich körperlich seien
dagegen wehrte er ist sicher sagt ist
getaucht es gibt wirklich eine
ursprüngliche bedeutung von schaden sie
jetzt nicht nur körperlich
naturalistisch zu verstehen und die geht
es ihm jetzt vor allem obwohl er betonte
das immer so eine doppelseitig kite hat
meine körperliche naturalistische
wenn sie ohne dieses gilt sicher auch
für die scham schon darum ist sie schon
kein ausschließliches geschlechts gefühl
dass sie nicht einmal ein
ausschließliches soziales geführtes es
gibt in jedem betrachter des wortes
charme ein ebenso ursprüngliche charme
vor sich selbst und einen sich schämen
vor sich selbst wie eine scham verändern
und dieses geld gilt gleich sehr für die
später zu schreiben der leiblich
sinnliches die für die geistig
seelischen schaden also scheele
unterschreibt jetzt hier schon mal auf
typische phänomen logischerweise
verschiedene formen der schaden worauf
richtet sich die schwaben die schwaben
gegen lieberman einen selbst und die
scham für andere also so etwas wie
fremdschämen dieses phänomen ist jetzt
auch neu der diskurs eingedrungen
auch das phänomen behandelt spieler in
seiner analyse weiteres zitat in einem
sinne des wortes aber gehört des wesens
zu schaden dass sie eine form das gefühl
ist von selbst ist also insofern dass
faire der selbstgefühl gehört und aller
schaden nämlich findet ein aktuelles
statt dem ich rückwendung auf einen
selbst wenden möchte diese äußerst
deutlich da wo wir schauen ganz
plötzlich einsetzt nachdem vorher zum
beispiel ein nach außen zielendes
starkes interesse an fluss zahn gefühlt
des eigenen selbst ausschloss also sagen
man sich selbst vergessen hat eine
mutter ist mit dem beispiel die etwa bei
einem brande ihr kind retten will zieht
nicht erst ein rocker sondern wird auch
im handy oder nackt aus dem hause
stürzen aus soweit erstes sicherung
erreicht ist und die rückwendung erfolgt
stellt sich die scham ein oder es kann
der liebe einer sehr schamhafte frau
zeichnet man momentan so stark sein dass
sich gefühlsmäßig ganz und seine mauern
anblick verloren ist obgleich ihre
situation allen anlass zu schauen und
sich trügen aber bei dem leisesten
nachlassen dieser liebevollen verloren
hat stellt sie keine bewusstsein ihrer
selbst und ihres leiters die sharp wie
kann man natürlich generell auch die
sache gerade umgedreht formulieren also
es kann auch ein stau auf der man sein
und so weiter also scheler denkt hier
sehr antiquierten kategorien
texten ist eben doch recht alt aber es
ist auffällig auf eine problematische
weise dass sie hier
zur analyse der charly mal eine frau
bringt also das scheint noch ein
bisschen aus dieser spät wilhelminischen
zeit zu stammen wo eben auch die
gesellschaftsordnung noch anders bis
jetzt als alles austauschbar natürlich
als ein beispiel
aber interessant trotz dieser
problematik dieser geschäftigkeit hier
ist dass er in der schau ist eine doppel
bewegung zu finden ist als einerseits
eine bezug auf sich selbst zugleich aber
auch in bezug auf etwas anderes und das
schadet erst dann eintritt wenn also
einer vorherigen zustand ein
selbstbewusstes zustand woltmann war
jetzt verloren oder vergessen in einem
zustand dann merkt man weiß nicht ob das
so ist das eigentlich besinnen sich auf
sich und dann stellt sich die scham 1
gingen sie an die sündenfall geschichte
im buch genesis der bibel wo auch die
scham erst bei adam und eva dann
eintritt wo sie eben frei sind und
selbstbewusstsein lang tag nach dem
essen verbannte die kenntnis und sich
dann nackt als nackt erkennen und sich
letztendlich bekleiden wollen um sich
schämen es findet also immer eine form
von rückwendung wie schwer er sagt auf
der selbst statt in deren dynamik die
scham beginnt stellt sich wieder ein
wenn man sich als allgemeines noch wenn
man sich als individuum gegeben heisst
sondern wenn die fühlbare intention des
anderen zwischen einem idealisierenden
und generalisieren denn einen schrank
wenn die eigene intention und die
erlebte gegen intention hinsichtlich
dieses unterschiedes nicht gleich sind
entgegengesetzte richtung haben ganz
analog fühlen wir auch schon leisten
wenn wir ein ganz individuelles erlebnis
dass unser eigen ist unter einen
allgemeinen begriff zu sanieren und
gleichsam feststellen dass dies mit leid
dass dies eben zeit
die urteils und begriff sphäre ist auch
da wir über uns selbst nachdenken und
aus den archiven erleben der erlebnisse
und reflektieren auf 17 gebäuden
gleichsam eine art
öffentlichkeit unseres bewusstseins in
die vene ganz individuellen erlebnis so
wenig gehören wie unser privatleben in
die zeitung
für mich ein schöner vergleich auch wenn
unsere wenn sie auch wenn unser
privatleben sich in der zeitung finden
würde dann würden wir uns schämen
und so ist auch das vieh in unseren
eigenen bewusstsein eine form von
öffentlichkeit haben eine form von
zeitung in der wir auch immer subjektiv
uns vor einer öffentlichkeit schämen
können finde ich eine sehr interessante
analyse und die zukunft dass er jetzt
hier von einer urteils und begriff
sphäre spricht die zur scham gehört und
das ist ja gerade eine dimension der
emotion wie wir sie nach skalieren des
user kennen gelernt haben seit die
rationale seite der scham
schaue man immer was bewusstwerdung zu
tun
das urteil mit einer erkenntnis weiteres
die talschaft an hieraus greift sich
aber nun auch warum das geschlechtsleben
trotzdem ist nicht im ursprungsland nur
ein ganz besonders ausgezeichnet das
anwendungsgebiet der schaden darstellen
gleichwohl zur tiefen nicht mit dem
schamgefühl verknüpft ist der grund
besteht darin dass es gleichzeitig dass
alle allgemein sste unseres lebens ist
das was wir mit allen tieren ja mit
allem jene teilen und doch auch das
individuellste insofern alles ist wie
hier in betracht kommen denn erfolge
oder misserfolge keiner mal forum gibt
und keinerlei richtung richter als die
empfindung selbst finde ich auch eine
sehr interessante bemerkung also das
geschlechtliche das geschlechtsleben ist
einerseits etwas sehr allgemeines das
teilten mit einem lebendigen zugleich
aber ist es eben etwas schambesetzt ist
weil man hier auch als individuum
betroffen ist
die nacktheit ist hier eben dieses
paradebeispiel wie es auch schon im buch
genesis geben angedeutet die nacktheit
ist dass der paradefall von schamhaft
ich keine auftritt aber auch das bloß
gestellt werden die bloßstellen
die muss man jetzt nicht nur körperlich
verstehen bloßgestellt zu werden sondern
es kann auch sein dass wir über eine
andere person etwas erzählt was sie
gerne für sich behalten was ihr dann
peinlich ist
auch dann würde sie sich stämme ja also
es geht um bloßstellung von etwas was
sehr individuell ist gegenüber einer
allgemeinheit gegen jemanden die nähe
der mann dieses gehe ihr verbergen
möchte altes zitat ist so schade
überhaupt ein schutz gefühl des
individuums und seines individuellen
wieder das gegen die gesamte sphäre des
allgemeinen so wird sich uns später das
spezifisch geschlechtlicher schamgefühl
als eine charakteristische folge
erscheint die dynamik zeil
grundbewegungen darstellen die bank die
geschäftsbeziehungen regeln einmal die
zwar beide frauen von liebe der
seelischen und der leidenschaft gebe
welche erstens auf werte gericht und
zwar auf hingabe an das objekt bezogen
ist und zugleich drittens das
qualifizierende und idealisieren dem
prinzip der herstellung geschlechts
beziehung ist ein andermal des kuchens
ähnlichen geschlechtstriebes der ersten
stelle verliert die lust zustände
zweitens anstelle von hingabe an das
objekt euro eintreiben auf ziemlich
eigen lust ist und der drittens das
quantifizieren und gattung smajic
prinzip der geschlechts beziehung
darstellt
ok also es gibt jetzt hier immer zwei
formen eine doppelung auch von der liebe
die ihn einmal als seelische liebe oder
als vergeistigte liebe und einmal ihr
als leidenschaftliche liebe verstanden
werden kann man kann vielleicht die
leidenschaft liebe ihrem sinne des eros
verstehen und die seelische erzählt der
agape oder auch der filia im
griechischen aber darüber kann man auch
noch mal genau dann später diskutieren
also immer diese doppelung es gibt eine
körperliche seite
diese emotion und es gibt aber auch eine
seelische oder geistige wesen das nicht
beide fähigkeiten wichtig wäre und keine
erlebten spannung zwischen diesen beiden
ob zwar auf dasselbe fremd
geschlechtlichen gerichteten kräfte wäre
der geschlechtlichen
nicht fähig dem nichts anderes ist die
geschlechtliche charme als das haus
schafe master zeug für die jeweiligen
dynamische konstellation dieser beiden
kräfte gegenüber der fremden oder der
eigene person
damit ist der zusammenhang des pure
charme phänomens als die menschen
subjektiv zu einem gefühle gewordenen
gegenreaktion und gleichsam angst des
individuellen in das allgemeine und
generelle des höheren wertes träger in
die träger der niedrigen werte zu
versinken
ein phänomen das auch nicht in der
früher genannten objektiven schaden
gegeben ist mit der spezifisch
geschlechtlichen charme deutlich
herausgestellt
schon wieder ein sehr sehr langes und
kompliziertes zitat also es geht hier
immer um das individuelle und das
allgemein also die spannung der scham
bestehen in diesem konflikt zwischen
allgemein und der angst die dazwischen
liegt ja das ist jetzt noch sehr
abstrakte zu mitteln mal schauen ob ihr
scheler noch ein paar konkrete zitat
beispiel hat auch wenn sie vielleicht
problematisch sind ja sagt walter scham
ist als ein schuldgefühl für das
individuelle selbst überhaupt nicht
notwendig für meine die wir das selbst
zahle für ein solches immer es gegeben
ist an mir oder einem anderen eben dies
zeigt auch dass die scham nicht wie
trauer wehmut einem ich haften die
gefühls qualität ist dann kann nicht
schaden falls sein so wie man wehmütig
und traurig ist und dann etwa diesen
gefühlen anderer sympathisch teilnimmt
vielmehr lebt das grund phänomen ihm
sich schwimmenden das immer einen sich
schämen über etwas ist und auf einen
sachverhalt bezogen der ist
versicherungs und ganz unabhängig von
unserem individuellen zustand fordert
diese sich schämt seine emotionale
bewegung eigene art die noch kein sich
nehmen einschließt das heißt kein
erlebte ich bezogenheit ist die für die
schweiz schon die tatsache
ich mich über mich schämen darum ist
auch die form des auftretens der charme
dass sich reden
das über kommen werden oder überlaufen
werden durch sie ja wieder schwieriges
zitat über das wir nachher noch genauer
reden müssen wichtig scheint mir hier
nur zu sein der sagt dass schemel ist
auf einen sachverhalt bezogen
also das ist eine position aale struktur
der schämen schäme mich darüber weil
oder dass das etwas gefangen ist und das
zeigt wieder dass hier eine rationale
oder kognitive dimension der scham
gegeben ist und dass qualifizierte
charme eben auch nach china untersucht
als eine emotionen genau eine emotionale
bewegung sagte das wäre vielleicht auch
noch ein wichtiger punkt in der charme
findet eine bewegung stadt kam es nichts
statisches sind etwas dynamisches und es
besteht in dieser spannung von
individualität und allgemeinheit
das können wir schon mal zusammenfassung
weiter sagt schäler in tiefgehenden
analogien steht die scham als leib
gefühl zu räkeln und zur aversionen und
als seelisches gift zu ihr folgt man hat
schamoni als die haut der mit bezeichnet
welche der realisierung des
geschlechtstriebes entgegen dass er
gesetzt sind also haupt dement das
bedeutet die grenzen oder die ja die
abgrenzungen die schutzmauern auch die
den geschlechts trick gesetzt sind
andererseits weil man sie schämte markt
ist andererseits ein mann sich auf ihr
geld
weil in den weil in diesem band hat eben
auch eine frau von ex zieht geliehen ist
die auch vielleicht manchmal eben
abstoßend zeigen kann dass körperliche
hat immer diese zwei seiten abstoßen und
anziehen also bezieht sich hier auf gold
alter sagt schneller eine gewisse
empirische verbindung beide emotionen
also
neben dem ekel und der scham die kein
bisschen nähe haben ist schon dadurch
hergestellt dass die besonders schaden
betont morgane des leibes in zetel
stärksten wollust und kitzel entzündung
stattfinden welche die regung des
geschlechtstriebs begleiten
zugleich die selben sind welche die
delegation und die uhr mit lehrern
vermitteln mit welchen vorgängen
einerseits selbst wieder gewisse wollust
empfindungen sich leicht verbinden
andererseits aber auch das primär aus
dem material für das auftreten von
ergebnis da ist jetzt schon fast schon
logisch oder fast schon ja medizinische
begründen diesen regionen liegen
natürlich sehr hart in kanda und so
versucht er jetzt neben mir die nähe von
scham und ekel zu begründen
anatomisch gewissermaßen das ist jetzt
ein bisschen insofern meinen augen
problematisch als er hier jetzt nur auf
einen naturalistischen basis
argumentiert er möchte es vielleicht
einfach nur bestärken durch diese
naturalistische analogie aber eigentlich
widerspricht der seiner these dass er ja
eben keine naturalistische
biologistische auffassung der spanier
vertreten erstellen aber interessante
bemerkung jedenfalls dass diese bereiche
serie anderes zitat ist geradezu das
natürliche seelen kleid unserer gesamten
geschlechtlichkeit mit recht hebt
friedrich nietzsche ganze tiefe des
wortes denn dank union vor die chance
sein will oppliger also das den körper
letztendlich abschließt oder einschließt
haben ja habe ich schon gesagt die
faktischen kleider sind nur eine
kristallisation der charme und eine
symbolisierung in ihrer künstlichen
künstlich hergestellten körper sehen wir
daher die dinge finden wo geschafft
richtig zu müssen wie wir die scham
gerade zu einer feinen aura von als
objektive schranken funken
unverletzlichkeit unberührbarkeit
gleichen die den menschen leib sphären
haft schließen doch darin liegt dass
objektive schaben phänomen das ist mir
als ob die griechischen gilt aber in
ihren bedeutendsten darstellung der
aphrodite diese aura mit unbeweglicher
kunst zur darstellung gebracht hätten
und als hätten ihr flüchtiger sinn nur
darum gefolgt die unbekleidete köpfchen
darzustellen weil sie zu gleicher zeit
die gewaltige kraft seele in sich
fühlten sie durch die äußerste
darstellung jene fast stofflichen scham
hört den gemeindlichen noch bei tiefer
zu verbergen als es alle bekleidung
vermöchte deswegen jetzt ein sehr
schönes bild
die scham nächste sagen eine sphäre eine
bedeckung sphäre die eben uns
unverletzlich und unberührbar machen so
also auch eine schutz eine
schutzfunktion aber hier kommt natürlich
dann wieder die in der furcht in der ggs
der nähe aber mir gefällt das sehr gute
natürliche seelen kleid was du jetzt
nicht stofflich zu denken ist weil eben
wie eine art von sphäre der ura sagt er
hier die uns umgibt resultat wir sind
gleich ende wieder anders sind die
beziehungen die zwischen der charme und
den gefühlen der angst der furcht und
der erfolg bestehen furcht dass die so
weit wie das jedem selbst reichende
kraft des vorfalls von gefahren die
schädigenden dreizehnter gefährden die
und fuhr auf den organismus eindringen
dies so dass diese dinge gleichzeitig
vorgestellt werden angst hingegen ist
eben dies sehr bevor fühlen aber ohne
die vorstellung der gefährden die un hat
die schar mit der furcht nur wenig
wieder angst aber umso mehr zu tun nicht
nur ausdrucks erscheinung zb zittern
voll schauen sie dann vor angst zins und
zwei identisch auch die ganze emotionale
haltung ist eine regung des schamgefühls
jener der angst ähnlich das widerstrebe
und die abwehrhaltung gegen die
gleichzeitig anlocken gegenstände ist
bei jeder charme insbesondere
wer eine gefühlte ein dass dies noch
nicht geschehen
und eben darum auch zugleich eine
ängstliche abwehrhaltung also nach
schülern zieht angst und scham
zumindest was ihre leibliche
manifestation angegrillt trifft das
zittern
csc nicht so das ist jetzt also die
zusammenfassung gewesen die präsentation
von schillers teilweise recht
problematische texte die aber dennoch in
ihrer bildhaftigkeit oder metaphorik
eine gewisse suggestivkraft haben und
über die wir uns jetzt gleich erweitert
halten wollen in der nächsten sitzung
geht es dann meine emotionen die leute
schon kurz hatten nämlich um die ecke
und zwar am anfang seines gleichnamigen
buch und jetzt bleibt mir nur noch mich
zu verabschieden und alles gute zu
wünschen
bis zur nächsten sitzung